well listen the old bailey has heard of
course some terrible cases in its
history but this has to be one of the
most disturbing that anybody really has
ever sat through the absolute depravity
of what Joseph makan embarked on in
April and May of this year the spree of
abductions sexual assaults and rapes of
11 victims over the course of two weeks
starting in Watford moving to London
then heading up to the northwest around
Manchester and Cheshire traumatizing his
victims leaving them with a trauma that
they will have to live with for the rest
of their lives and the jury actually in
finding Joseph McCann guilty of 37
counts said that they wanted to pass on
their gratitude their thanks and their
admiration to those victims who all did
all they could to help with the
prosecution of Joseph McCann this is a
man who never even attended court during
the trial kept giving the prosecution
authorities the court system the
runaround telling them that he would
come to court and then changing his mind
not added to some delays in the
proceedings here the judge he wanted to
give him some latitude to ensure that he
could attend court but after a while he
told the jury that Joseph McCann was not
going to be attending his own trial was
not going to give evidence in his own
defense and today after just a few hours
of deliberation the jury has come back
and found him guilty of all 37 counts
this is my look back at this very
disturbing case the moment police chase
down one of the country's most wanted
criminals the end of a short but
horrific campaign of kidnap and rape but
there are now real questions about
whether Joseph McCann should ever have
been free to commit those crimes in the
first place he'd been on an
indeterminate sentence after release he
was jailed again for further offenses
but then freed automatically
halfway through this later prison term
without parole board oversight this is a
very concerning case this was a dreadful
dreadful set of offenses and in this
case I think there was clearly an
individual error McCown should have been
referred to the pro board after he'd
committed further offense it is I'm very
confident it in no circumstances the pro
board wouldn't have rereleased him
Joseph Mekons two weeks of terror began
at 3:59 a.m. on the 21st of April his 21
year old victim had left the prism
nightclub in Watford and was walking
home when he grabbed her at knifepoint
and forced her into his car almost five
hours later having been raped in her own
home McCann drove to this Watford
filling station his victim sat in the
passenger seat too terrified to move as
he bought condoms in the forecourt shop
before eventually letting her go the
police were alerted later that morning
for more than four days when he then
struck for a second time
Joseph makaan was not picked up by
police senior officers here see they
took the allegations made by the first
victim very seriously but they did all
they could to track him down
Joseph McCann second victim had been
walking home in the early hours of the
25th of April she was forced into his
vehicle at knifepoint by now McCann was
driving a silver people carrier when
later that afternoon he abducted a 21
year old woman from a street in Edgware
Northwest London she was bundled into
the vehicle alongside the victim
abducted 12 hours earlier both were
raped and sexually assaulted before
McCann drove to Watford and is seen here
on security camera trying to book a room
at a B&B regularly glancing out to check
the two young women were still in the
vehicle back outside here McCann's
victims had been through the most
horrendous ordeal knew it wasn't over
somehow the oldest woman managed to
summon up the strength and the courage
to pick up a bottle of vodka from inside
his vehicle
he returned she smashed it over his head
and the pier escaped I can't even begin
to imagine how they were feeling whilst
they were detained some of them for up
to 14 hours whilst they were being
threatened was their loved ones being
threatened what they must have genuinely
been in fear for their lives and also
forced by him to engage in instant
unthinkable and depraved behavior McCann
went silent for 10 days before striking
again embarking on a horrific spree of
abduction rape and assault over the
course of just half a day in hustling to
north of Manchester he forced his way
into a woman's home tied her to her bed
and raped her 11 year old son and 17
year old daughter hours later a 71 year
old woman was abducted as she finished
shopping at a supermarket in Ramsbottom
she was raped and me to drive her own
car as McCann abducted other victims
first a thirteen-year-old girl snatched
from the street in Heywood the 71 year
old woman drove them to Knutsford
services on the m6 where the pair
managed to escape just over half an hour
later McCain's final victims - 14
year-old girls were abducted from a
street in Congleton in Cheshire but by
this time the police were closing in
after a short vehicle chase in which he
crashed his car he was later found
hiding up a tree his spree of abduction
and rape over but not before he
subjected 11 victims to an ordeal
they'll have to live with for the rest
of their lives